hello everyone welcome to Khan Academy's
daily homeroom for those of you all who
aren't familiar with what this is ever
since we had the mass school closures
because of the cove at 19 all of us at
Khan Academy is a not-for-profit with a
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere realized
that it's our duty to do whatever we can
to support students parents and teachers
through this crisis so obviously over
many years we've been building resources
in math and English and language arts
and early learning Khan Academy kids you
can see Kody bear right behind me going
all the way through high school level
Sciences and SAT prep but we realized
when the schools were going to get
clothes that people needed even more so
we've been doing webinars for parents
and teachers to understand how to
structure things we've been releasing
schedules on what students how they
could structure their days based on
different age groups and we've been
doing this live stream this daily
homeroom so that we can feel connected
in this time of social distancing we do
have a cool announcement just over the
yesterday we released what we're calling
learning plans on Khan Academy and I
think you're going to see some of the
link there you go the link is right
there it's magical there I can get my
there you go what Philippe is doing a
better job it's getting fancier every
day but if you go there what you're
going to see is we got a lot of feedback
from especially students and parents
saying all right
the schedules were useful I understand
that I could do maybe 40 minutes of math
and take a break too and do 40 minutes
of reading etc etc but over the course
of the next two months or even five
months as we go through summer what our
reasonable goals for me or for my child
how do I make sure that me either myself
or my child is keeping up so that
they're ready for next school year so
this is a week-by-week learning plan
that sets goals for you if you're the
student or your child if you're the
parent to be on track and this first
learning plan we've done is focused on
math Khan Academy has much more than
just math but math is one of those core
subject areas where it's really valuable
to make sure that you don't fall behind
obviously even before this Kovan crisis
we have talked a lot about the
importance of mastery learning about not
being pushed ahead while
you still have gaps that accumulate over
time these Swiss cheese gaps and that
Khan Academy can help fill you in and
then you can imagine with five months of
not being in school now it's that much
more important to fill in those gaps and
to keep learning and just to underline
that our partners at the nwea there are
a non profit assessment body they just
released a report yesterday because they
have historical data on what's known as
the summer learning loss or the Summer
Slide normally you have three months of
loss over the summer not just not
learning but oftentimes forgetting now
it might be five months and in that
world it could be as much as a year of
learning loss so please take a look at
those learning plans and give us
feedback the other thing I'd like to
just set a shout out of thank you
Khan Academy we are not-for-profit we
are funded by philanthropic donations
you own as much as Khan Academy as I or
anyone else it has no ownership it's a
public charity and we need your support
even before the crisis we were running
at a deficit and now our server costs
etc are growing up many fold and we're
trying to put out more support so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about donating I do want to give a
special thanks to several corporations
who've stepped up recently including
Bank of America
AT&T google.org and Novartis that's been
a major help but we need more we're
still running at a deficit to do all of
this so with that today's a live stream
I thought we could have a little bit of
fun we have fun all the time but we're
going to keep it a little bit freeform
if you're watching this over YouTube
where you're watching it over Facebook
put any question you might possibly be
curious about there we have team members
that are looking at them and everything
is fair game dan dan is here and he's
gonna help me out identifying what folks
are saying but you know we can we're
more than happy to answer questions
about some of what I just talked about
how do you structure your day questions
about learning in education we're happy
to at least think about questions about
some of the the healthcare stuff that's
going on as much as we are qualified to
do so economic things or just other
things that are going on in your life
this we're gonna we're gonna inside our
organization we have these things called
ask me anything we're gonna make this
and ask me anything version of our live
stream so ask us
literally anything and let's see I'm
gonna see some of our team members are
starting to put out so susana from
youtube susana garcia Dominguez and
since I know you've been asking good
questions I remember your name off of
YouTube as asking will you be releasing
a learning plan for first grade so that
is an excellent question so that your
question by itself is a little bit of a
push for us to do it first grade is an
interesting overlap subject or grade
level for us because Khan Academy kids
goes up through first grade and then the
Khan Academy that is not Khan Academy
kids we have to come up with a better
name for that because that's still for
kids and adults
it starts at that kindergarten first
grade level so I think what your
question is a really good push hopefully
over the next couple of days or weeks we
can work with the Khan Academy kids team
to maybe put something together or put
something together that's a hybrid of
Khan Academy kids and the math because
these first learning plans are math
focused on on non Khan Academy kids Khan
Academy all right from Facebook Jackie
Raquelle me says could you please share
what software you used to record video
lessons I would love to use the writing
tool to explain in better details with
video for my students thank you so much
so Jackie it sounds like you might be a
teacher and I know a lot of teachers
even before this crisis or interested in
making I guess you could say Khan
Academy style videos and especially with
school closures it's even more important
so what I use and it's good that I'm
that it's right here so let me see if I
can show this to you I'm thinking it
there's a little bit of bumping into all
sorts of stuff this is a Wacom tablet I
use this is a I've upgraded over the
years I used to have a kind of a smaller
$80.00 one I think this one costs about
$200 and it will come with a pen that
looks like this and so that's what I use
to write when I'm doing it this
microphone that you see here this is the
microphone that I use and once again all
of this is kind of upgrade you don't
need these types of things to to do a
decent video if you just have even you
know your regular headphone microphone
that's probably
fish into the first several years of
Khan Academy I had a $80 tablet and I
just used a standard you know like $20
headset that you could find and the I
use an art program in the early days I
was using Microsoft Paint now I use
sketchbook SketchBook Pro which is just
a nice drawing application and the way
that I capture the drawing and my voice
is I use Camtasia to screen capture and
Mac Camtasia isn't the only tool there's
other tools that can allow you to do
some screen capture and I just what I do
is I capture a portion I do a 1280 by
720 pixel rectangle of my art tool and
that's why you don't see all of the
widgets and the tools because they're
out there outside of the recording
window so that's what I do I just
I click record I I try to do things
fairly informally I think it's really
valuable when you're making videos that
it's not overly scripted because I think
the the listener can detect if you are
going through it with them or not so I
try to keep it reasonably extemporaneous
and and and low key but whatever works
for you but encourage you to definitely
keep going with that
alright so from Facebook Rick Cornett
asks how can I set up a science
curriculum for my 6th and 7th grader
math is set up by grade level but
science is not that's a great question
Rick so Khan Academy we don't yet it is
our aspirations we don't yet have it
explicit science curriculum for middle
school students with that said and I've
said this a couple of times on the live
stream I think a 6th grader a 7th grader
is ready to start engaging on parts of
the high school sciences so for example
high school biology which is on Khan
Academy I am confident that your
children especially if you're there to
support them can start learning the
basics of biology and frankly it's very
relevant right now to learn about DNA
RNA viruses bacterial evolution natural
selection obviously you know what the
viruses evolution and natural selection
is happening before our eyes in real
time so I would definitely look at the
high school biology is a great thing for
potentially 6 or 7th graders they
definitely have the math background for
it and then even the early
in chemistry where you're learning about
the periodic table of elements what
elements are the basics of bonding the
basics of balancing chemical equations
there's nothing there that's cognitively
beyond a sixth or seventh grader
especially if they have some supports
and physics is a little bit more
mathematical but there is even elements
of the physics where you know maybe the
one dimensional motion or Newton's laws
could be a really interesting thing to
tackle and if you're if your students
your children are able to do that now
they're gonna have a serious leg up when
they get to true high school level
science so let's see we have another
question here well when I picked up my
tablet everything got messed up I'm
let's see so from Facebook s Wayne Smith
says will you consider Khan Academy
project-based learning activities great
question so this is something we've
always thought about doing and and in
back in the day we've actually did
released a few pieces of content on it
but I think the lens you're asking is
this while schools are closed or as we
go into the summer maybe in these
learning plans we can articulate things
to do above and beyond the traditional
academic skill development or the stuff
that could reinforce that so I think
that's a great idea
this is if if our team or maybe we can
partner with some folks who can maybe
supplement the learning plans and the
schedules with that type of resource I
think it would be cool and it's just a
matter of our capability in our
bandwidth but I definitely think there's
there's value in that so yeah so I have
a question for you this is asked for
almost every single live stream that we
do it's a question on how did you start
Khan Academy and probably more
importantly people don't know about this
part which is who did you go to for help
who did I go to help when I started Khan
Academy or like when I needed help when
I was a kid who did you go to when you
started for help when you started Khan
Academy oh yeah so for those of y'all
who don't know and you can probably do a
youtube search and find videos of me
giving a long-winded explanation of how
kind of has me started I've been running
off of that story for a long time
but it still there's a lot of folks who
still don't maybe know that story as
much so back in 2004 I was I had just
gotten married I was my original
background was in technology and in math
but I had gone to business school and I
was now working in as an investment
analyst of all things and it just came
out of conversation after my wedding my
12 year old cousin Nadia at the time was
visiting and she was having trouble in
math and so I said Nadia I am confident
that you can master mathematics how
about when you go back to New Orleans
which is where also where I was born I'm
willing to tutor you remotely I was
living in Boston at the time and she
agreed and long-standing like a lot of
you students listening she was 12 years
old she she she wanted to learn but she
for some you know for many reasons she
had accumulated gaps in her knowledge
and had convinced herself that maybe she
wasn't quote good at math many of you
know many of you parents might relate
her mom Nazareth auntie you know she was
saying yeah I'm worried about Nadia
she's losing her confidence here and so
those tutoring sessions I was doing it
remotely I think a lot of you teachers
are finding yourselves in that kind of a
circumstance now because of the closures
and I was getting on the phone I we
didn't have things like zoom and
hangouts and live streams back then but
I was trying to find ways that we could
see each other's writing and things like
that but but slowly but surely Nadia was
able to catch up with her class it was
actually unit conversion that she was
having trouble with then she actually
got a little bit ahead of her class then
I became what I call a tiger cousin and
I called up her school and I said you
know I really think Nadia Rahman should
retake that placement test from last
year that put her in that current math
track and you know they famously said
who are you and I said I'm her cousin
and they let her surprisingly take that
test and that same Navia who thought she
wasn't good at math only a few months
before was then put into an advanced
class and that same Nadia who thought
that she couldn't understand unit
conversion when she was 12 by the time
she was 13 she was taking college-level
classes at the University of New Orleans
and I tell you that story only partially
to show off on behalf of my cousin but
more to tell many of you parents and
many of you students out there that are
thinking that you are not good at
something it has nothing to do with your
innate ability those the subject matter
is not fundamentally differ
it's likely because you have gaps and
that's where Khan Academy hopefully has
your back and you know the silver lining
of what we're going through right now
over the next two months and probably
the next five months is this is a great
opportunity to leverage Khan Academy to
fill in those gaps we had Tim
Vanderburgh on a couple of days ago
amazing teacher out of history in
California who makes all of his sixth
graders start Khan Academy at the very
basic starting with the arithmetic
course which starts literally at 1+1 but
if you know that material you go through
it really fast but that's the way he
ensures that his kids don't have gaps
and he has a student population that you
know starts the year 90% is well below
grade level and then he finishes the
year where they're able to fill in their
gaps and most of them are accelerated or
are able to move ahead
so anyway going back to the story I was
kind of hooked I started tutoring
Nadia's younger brothers as well then
word gets around my family that free
tutoring is going on and I found myself
10 15 cousins family friends around the
country and Khan Academy you know I had
this background in in software
engineering and I said well there there
aren't good resources for my cousin's to
get practice and immediate feedback what
if I could make some of that and also
provide a dashboard for me as their
coach or their teacher or their tutor so
that I could understand where their gaps
were so that I could dig a little bit
deeper and assign appropriate work for
them etc and that was the first Khan
Academy had nothing to do with videos
which many people associated with and it
was in 2006 I was showing off this
software to a friend at a dinner party
as you can imagine I'm a very fun dinner
party guest and he said Sal this is all
cool but how are you scaling your actual
lessons up and I said told him his name
is Uli ramzan have to give him full
credit I said zuly it's hard to scale my
lessons I feel like I'm repeating the
same thing I'm answering the same
question often times over and over and
he says well why don't you record some
of your lessons as YouTube videos and
upload them for your cousins and I
initially thought it was a horrible idea
I said no YouTube is for cats playing
piano but I got home I went home that
weekend got over the idea that it wasn't
my idea and I gave it a shot and then
that took on a life of its own and you
know I could go more in depth but by
2009 I just had Frank you know this was
about three four years into this cousin
project five years into it
I had trouble focusing on my day job
there were about a hundred thousand
people who are using it every month and
I said surely if I set this up as a
not-for-profit philanthropists will
donate to this because the the impact we
could have on the world is is huge if we
translate it into the language of the
world go across subjects and grades and
you know whenever you try anything start
anything entrepreneurial you have to
start with that delusional optimism that
surely the world will conspire to make
this happen and you usually realize
quite quickly that it was a little bit
delusional but after about eight nine
months of living off of savings and
openly it was probably the one of the
most stressful times in my life I you
know had given up a good career and my
first child had just been born but after
about ten months all of a sudden some
some philanthropist started to come out
of the woodwork and by 2010 we were able
to become a real organization so anyway
you got me on my soapbox telling the
origin story of Kahn Academy but I'm
happy to answer any other questions you
have on that front as well South follow
up to that oh yes
so I've youtubes yeah on YouTube Sophia
says great where is Nadia now and she
also has a sister called not yet good so
Nadia is now if I'm doing the math
correctly she is 28 years old she lives
in New York I was just zoomed conference
calling with her and her family a couple
of nights ago obviously everyone's
worried about the situation especially
in New York but she is doing a master's
and hopefully a PhD as well in clinical
psychology she wants to become a kind of
a clinical psychologist therapist type
type person so she's we're very proud of
her she is doing well although I often
joke with her that there's a lot riding
on her success better early intervention
ends up anyway yeah she's on track and
Sal Facebook Scott yang on Facebook
asked why is there a giant bear behind
you I don't think everyone knows who
Cody is there's a giant bear behind me
oh yeah you're right there's a giant
bear but no I so so my my mom has
actually kept saying she's like you
I like these live streams but your
background is really horrible like you
have some licked random junk behind you
you have to fix your back and so I
actually went looking this morning I
right before this I was actually on on
CNN and my mom's like if you're gonna be
on CNN you got to get a good background
Sal and I just start digging around for
what we have that could make a decent
background and this is what I found and
for those of you don't know this is Kody
bear gazing over my shoulder he's kind
of the primary character and Khan
Academy kids so this is a reminder too
that that's available for you and and
and yeah and maybe you know having Kody
glare at you will be a reminder to keep
learning so let's see I I there's a
bunch of questions I'm seeing here Dan
but feel free to jump in with Morrissey
youtube or if jane says what do I do
when my brain gets stressed in reading
or math so there's there's a lot to
unpack with what that might what that
might be you know one thing that I've
talked a lot about in this livestream in
other place this is just the value of
meditation and meditation it does not
have to be something fancy it literally
can be you know before you embark on
something give yourself two minutes and
just sit there and you know close your
eyes if it's useful soften your gaze and
just try to just try to observe your
thoughts and what you find is the more
you do it and the more consistently you
do it
you start to realize that you aren't
your thoughts that you can observe your
thoughts and the more that you can
observe your thoughts the less that they
the less overwhelming that they can
become and you know I think we've all
felt some of what you might be feeling
RF which is you know you're reading
something and you're like wait did I
understand that properly and you keep
rereading that same sentence I used to
do that a lot I think in math you know
you're in a test or something or you're
doing a problem and you're like you know
there's a process in your brain to say
oh well you know how to do it this is
hard what if you don't know I get this
answer right you might fail your math
class and and and and then that becomes
a little bit debilitating because it
doesn't allow your your brain to enter
into kind of a state of flow so that's
one tip I have is you know just
meditation actually physical exercise
can be
there is some evidence actually a lot of
evidence they're just getting that brain
flowing running etc it releases those
endorphins and then when you when you
sit down to do something like reading or
or math or anything that you might find
stressful in your life and you just
realize that you know you know I'm just
gonna do it see what happens so I think
the more that you just give yourself
permission to just be be in the moment
don't try to think too much about what's
happened in the past or what might
happen in the future but just like oh
this is fun
I'm here I'm this sentient being in the
universe that is going to read this
entertaining book or that gets to puzzle
through these interesting math questions
I think you have that attitude and it
can really help you know I I've
considered myself lucky that you know
throughout my life I've I've always kind
of taken a fun attitude a kind of an
adventurous attitude
whenever I see a test or something and I
think it's really helped me is like oh
this is fun it's a bunch of puzzles and
I don't try to think too much about what
the outcomes might be because that that
can be a little bit stressful sometimes
how that was wonderful we have a related
question from Selena Chang on YouTube hi
Sal how can I find a passion project to
pursue while in high school
great question Selena so meditation
might help there sit under the tree for
a little while and have it and have an
Enlightenment experience or what I would
do is just really reflect like you know
keep a lookout in the world for where
are their problems to be solved and this
crisis were in is highlighting a lot of
problems that have always existed and
they're introducing a set of new ones
I've talked at this livestream I think
there's many opportunities for service
projects right now it could be figuring
out safe ways to get groceries for say
elderly people in your community ways to
get food you know we're going through a
financial situation where a lot of
people have lost their jobs and I never
thought it would be this way in the
United States but there could be there's
there's people probably not too far from
where you live who are worried about
where their next meal is going to come
from so are there ways to coordinate you
know just dropping off the basics to
folks get milk eggs bread things like
that are there ways to
to help with some of the social
distillation people are feeling you know
I my mom she's living by herself in New
Orleans and you know she's the age
population that's high risk for Co vid
so she and she's watching the news all
day and she's getting stressed so I've
been telling you know it's always
important for me to keep in touch with
my mom but even more like for her mental
health it's super important for me to to
keep connected and that she can see my
kids and that she doesn't feel isolated
but there's a lot of people in her
situation who might be a little bit
older who are alone at home who might
not have someone who is checking in with
them on them on a daily basis maybe
there's maybe there's opportunities
around that if you're more inclined on
the invention side of things you know
are there gloves you can create that not
only protect you but disinfect things as
you touch them you know you can imagine
a glove that you know has made some
material or it's doused in some material
that when you when you when you use it
not only does it protect you but it
protects other people as well I mean you
you you can keep imagining more and more
things that that could help solve a lot
of problems for the world right now or
could have solve problems that existed
even before but I would just reflect on
that and then when you feel some energy
around something just run with it and as
I've talked about in other live streams
there's an opportunity here the silver
lining is a lot of the things that
historically keep young people super
busy with you know hours of homework
every night and and this practice and
that practice a lot of that's gone now
and so you have more time to be able to
dig deep into something you know if it's
coding there's resources on Khan Academy
and people talk about project-based
learning that is one area where Khan
Academy has what I would describe as
project-based learning to be able to
code and create things you can make apps
to solve interesting problems so yeah
you know the world's your oyster right
now it's a great opportunity to do that
type of thing but make sure it's
something that appeals to you you're not
trying to do it for other people you're
not saying oh how will this look on a
college application do it because it's
authentically something you're
interested in and by the way if you do
that it actually will look good on
application because it'll be truly you
and it'll be authentic so there are
questions let's see from Facebook Sandra
Edwards asks so much has changed over
the
last month what positive changes have
you noticed coinciding with more people
being online well you know it's hard to
talk about too many positive things in
it because it's a tough tough period
right now some of the positive things
I've seen and this transcends Khan
Academy is you know what I just talked
about this crisis has made me realize
that I have to stay connected with more
of my friends and family many of whom I
might have not talking to spoken to for
a while so I'm making sure that I'm
calling up cousins and uncles and
friends from high school so in a strange
way the social distancing is making us
think beyond just the people that we
normally see on a day-to-day basis so
that might be a silver lining that we're
connecting with a lot more people
I think this crisis reminds us of what's
really important all of us get caught up
in the day-to-day if you're student
you're like oh I got that assignment do
I got that homework am I gonna the SAT
college what's my career choice but if
you think about it that's those are
important things and obviously you know
US adults we're always thinking about oh
you know that project I'm working on or
that next goal or or that next event or
whatever it might be and all of those
things are important but they're not the
most important thing the most important
thing is your health your mental health
your connections your support networks
and I think it's times like this when
you realize just how fragile we are how
fragile and some certain ways society
can be that it refocuses you on on on
you know the really important things the
things that really fulfill us as human
beings versus these hoops that we keep
jumping through our whole lives and
maybe when we're older we realized why
did we jump through so many hoops
why didn't I spend more time with my
parents while they were alive why didn't
I connect with those cousins when I had
a chance at cetera et cetera so I think
that is bringing that you know we're
spending more time with family that's
positive on the education side of things
that you know this is a very suboptimal
situation but the silver lining is some
of these techniques that are having to
happen where students are having to
build a little bit more independence a
little bit more agency and they're still
supported by parents and teachers that
skill is actually a super valuable skill
it's more valuable than you know knowing
how to
your polynomial is to be is learning how
to learn and so I'm hoping for the
students who are able to build that
muscle hopefully many of y'all are
listening right now that's gonna pay
dividends if you can keep applying it in
the summer and keep applying it your
whole life
because it's not like you know the days
of going to K through 12 and then going
to college and then just having skills
that you will use the rest of your life
until you retire those days are over
you're going to have to be a lifelong
learner and so it's a great time to to
kind of take that agency on your on your
own
so that that could be a silver lining as
well but obviously you know if I were to
list a lot of the the suboptimal things
right now this would get long but a good
question to focus on on the silver
linings so let's see there's a question
from Facebook Seif Siddiqui asks can you
please add subjects of Commerce as per
Indian Curriculum please so aside that's
actually a subject close to my heart as
I described my my career before Khan
Academy was I was a financial analyst
and so we actually do have it's not
mapped to the Indian curriculum but I
will say if you want the intuition of
Finance and Accounting Khan Academy does
have some resources for you already so
feel free to look at that content I made
a lot of that actually when I was a
financial analyst and I saw that you
know even some of the junior analysts
that we were hiring who went to fancy
colleges with 4.0 GPA s when I asked
some very basic questions like okay
there's two identical houses the rent on
one house is X the other house costs Y
to buy which one should i buy rent or
buy and it's a Arad buy why I'd buy the
second house and they're like okay now
that price is doubled on the second
house while the rent is the same on the
first house now which one and they're
like oh you're right and and so we try
to give those types of frameworks of how
you can think how very calming lis
complex situations in the economy or
finance could be broken down into fairly
simple and intuitive framework so I
definitely check some of that content
out and I hope in the future we can do
something like a more formal finance
accounting capital markets type course
on on Khan Academy we actually have a
lot of personal finance content it's a
partnership with Bank of America around
better money habits we also have some
career content around that so check that
content out as well
so let's see there is a question
YouTube explorer questioner others so
it's a testimonial well that's nice
you're saying amazing Sal you're being
generous thank you for giving me the
opportunity to better myself and make
myself useful and find more purpose in
my life
well Explorer question are on YouTube
that's why all of us here at Khan
Academy to be clear kind of kept me is
much more than me and much more than me
and Dan there's two hundred plus other
folks who are we're doing a lot of work
and thousands of people but that's why
we wanted to dedicate our lives to this
mission because at you know at the end
if we can empower millions of folks
that's going to have a multiplier
billions of folks that's going to have a
multiplier effect for the world you know
I I'd sometimes daydream that you know
the person who one day can find the
vaccine for the next pandemic or solves
an energy crisis or Brokers peace
between nations you know in in in in not
too far our future says yes and I'm in
this position because I was able to get
my start or with some help from from
Khan Academy so it really is motivating
for us to hear those types of things so
from YouTube quality material asks
firstly mister Sal how are you dealing
with the quarantine hope you're doing
well so quality material mister material
maybe I should call you thanks for
asking I I'm doing fine you know
obviously this is a challenging time for
everyone but I remind myself this is the
whole world is going through this and
relatively speaking I find myself in a
very fortunate situation you know knock
on wood
have my health my family does we are you
know we we have a backyard we have a
park nearby that we can go to staying
socially distanced appropriately you
know my kids are I'm really enjoying
time with my kids you know it's hard at
first trying to do work and at the same
time they're screaming in the in the
next room but we've kind of got a new
normal now and that's once again it's
reminded me like you know sometimes when
you're doing work and your child is
screaming or saying Dada Dada Dada let
me show you the thing I made
you're kind of like oh where we go away
for a second I need to finish this
really important email but there's
something about this crisis that makes
you say well maybe this email isn't as
important as hanging out with my
eight-year-old or whatever so I've
actually enjoyed it to kind of recenter
myself in a lot of ways I think my wife
and I you know we were just talking
yesterday about you know having all of
various events or social things or
things you have to go to travel all get
cancelled
and just us up being home and having
quality time and it's it's kind of nice
so III I consider myself very fortunate
obviously I have a job where not only do
I have a job now a lot of people who are
working in restaurants and other you
know they're losing their jobs now so
for those of us who are able to keep
working and keep having an income
incredibly fortunate and I and I
consider myself fortunate that we have a
role to play to help and in this
situation on that on the education
dimension and getting information out
dimension so thanks for asking
but I I consider myself very very lucky
and I hope you're doing well as well mr.
material so we are almost out we
actually are out of time I may be having
too much fun but we're here every day
and we're gonna do more of these just
super open-ended asking me anything's
really enjoying the questions and all
I'll say is thanks for joining hope
everyone has a really really good
weekend and I'll just remind folks if
you're in a position to do so we are
not-for-profit we are running at a
deficit and every donation matters so
anything you could do to help support
Khan Academy would would mean a lot
thank you and stay safe and healthy
you